Fiser has entered into a partnership
with a German biotechnology company
called bio and tech to develop a Cove a
vaccine that uses cutting-edge
technology called messenger RNA
technology for the last 10 years Wall
Street and biotechnology companies have
been very excited about this idea and
what essentially it is is trying to pack
the cells into the body in order to make
them into drug factories and as a result
in this case technology would be used to
make portions of the virus's spike
protein in order to induce an immune
response that will create neutralizing
antibodies to the virus
the problem with this approach is there
has never been an approved mRNA product
the current platform the nucleoside
modified mRNA has only been around for
about 3 years we've been studying it for
a little longer than that so it's really
a brand new thing people have done a few
phase one trials a phase 2 trial just
started for Koga at 19 but that you it's
a brand new drug so it's very early for
it to to be made in something to give to
people there are real advantages to mRNA
the one big one is that it's very fast
once researchers know the makeup and
composition of a virus they can quickly
tailor the mRNA approach to the virus
the COBIT sequence was published by the
Chinese in January or so within a couple
weeks we had a vaccine ready to be
tested and moderna was farthest along
and biotech also had RNA vaccines that
are already in clinical trials two
months after the sequence was published
so that that's not something you can do
with many other kinds of vaccines
now what Pfizer can bring to this
project is incredible size and its
resources there are things that large
pharmaceutical companies like Pfizer can
do as small biotechnology companies
cannot do and as a result by pushing all
those resources on this project Pfizer
can can push it farther and faster than
a biotechnology company like biotech can
do on its own
Pfizer's also bringing Finizio its
planning to spend about a billion
dollars without knowing whether the
vaccine is going to work which is very
unusual what is the cost
we need to contribute the solution to
cough it if not us then who but there's
no other way that you can deliver unless
if you take enormous risk and to thank
you a lot of technical risks right now I
didn't want glad this would be afraid of
taking money right so I said let's let's
go meatless let's go look at then do it
I think that a vaccine will be developed
because I think the technology is good
enough it's being done by the right
people the big question is how soon and
that depends on a lot of things like
what's the incidence of the disease when
you do a trial with 30,000 people you
have to show protection and if nobody is
getting the disease you can never show
protection and and those trials go on
for 10 years so I just don't know how
fast it will be before it's given to
people but it's not just about finding a
vaccine that works it's also about
producing sufficient quantities of doses
to get the vaccine to the population and
that part is really really hard
Pfizer only believes that they can make
as much as twenty million doses this
year
so if Pfizer gets early use approval
from
the FDA for the vaccine that they're
working on with bio in fact they in the
best case scenario this is truly best
case we'll be able to push vaccines to
vulnerable populations emergency health
care workers on the frontlines and then
the hope is that that can be expanded in
2021 either and biotech have worked
together on mRNA technology before
Fiser knows the technology it believes
in the technology but you know in the
case of this vaccine in the case of the
moderna vaccine we are in kind of
unchartered territory